c'est par un hommage à rené clair
président du jury que s'est ouvert hier
soir le festival de cannes noster
traditionnel des soirs de première avec
en plus des créatures fellinienne et
claudia cardinale parmi les rares
grandes vedettes présentes à cette
soirée de gala en raison des élections
présidentielles françaises la campagne
électorale il est bien évident que
longtemps ce festival n'aura pas cette
année le rayonnement des années
précédentes mais il ya tout de même
beaucoup de monde à cannes beaucoup de
professionnels pour ce grand marché du
film deux films sont très attendus
l'un français dans la compétition
réalisé par alain resnais avec jean paul
belmondo promo dette stavisky il sera
projeté au début de la semaine prochaine
l'autre italien de federico fellini à
marquantes qui précisément était projeté
hier soir amarcord est la chronique
d'une petite ville des bords de
l'adriatique dans les années 30 une
satire sociale caricaturé mais le
réalisateur italien avec chute le
qualificatif d'autobiographique malgré
les réminiscences tout est
autobiographique
tout ce que nous créons témoigne de nous
mêmes ce qu'ils m'ont bien dit noise thê
binh dinh cibox foot il je réfute le
mode autobiographique hommes et film
pour mon oeuvre et à la définition
biographie filmée du camp s'étend à tout
réduire à des fêtes qui me seraient ou
non personnellement arriver technip
hausse mais c'est la cas douter au nom
un cadeau commun il termine ses
personnels
les années 30 sous le régime fasciste
traité en dérision le fascisme liés pour
l'auteur à l'ignorance l'infantilisme la
mesquinerie et la vénération de mythes
ridicule
le public de cannes hier soir n'a pas
fait un accueil délirant un film dans
les quelques longueurs n'estompe pas la
beauté ironique et tendre
monica vitti membres du jury paru
l'avoir appréciée